today I want to talk about being
different so I find that a lot of
entrepreneurs are afraid to be different
I find that what what we often do is
look up to other entrepreneurs we look
at the people in our industry and we say
well that's how things are done so
that's what I'm going to do and you end
up with something that is mediocre
that's average it's not so different
from the competition and if you're going
up against big players in an industry
why is somebody going to pick you over
them they're not unless you're doing
something that's very different and
young don't get me wrong I'm a big
believer in modeling success it's the
name of my channel right modeling the
Masters in name my youtube channel but
when I'm saying that you should model
Elon Musk and Bill Gates and Donald
Trump and steve jobs and Oprah Winfrey
Martha Stewart and all these tycoons in
the entrepreneurial world I don't want
you to be like them I don't want you to
try to be like Elon Musk I want you to
take the things that you like from each
of these people to help you become the
best version of yourself you want a
model success in a way that makes you
different that makes you irreplaceable
that makes you somebody that nobody else
can be like and so don't be afraid to be
different the best thing I found that my
youtube channel is I made the channel
because I wish it existed right the N
stressful series a top 10 series of talk
about a few times I wish that those
things already existed on someone else's
channel so I didn't have to do the work
I just wanted to be a consumer and I
made it selfish it for me and then
shared it and you guys wanted it it's
the same thing that I have with my book
right I'm writing the book because I
wish somebody else had written it
because I don't want to have to do all
the hard work and research that comes
with writing this thing and the year of
my life and putting it together I wish
somebody else did it but it's not out
there and by doing something that I'm
passion but that I love doing that I
feel is missing then it's going to be
different and I think you can apply that
same strategy to your business look at
what you wish existed look at what you
are yearning for and chances on so many
other people who want that too so go out
and create it don't be afraid to be
different all right let's get to your
questions first up Tamara I totally love
your rants thanks Tamara and I love your
openness you're honest with us and
another question is about you nicely at
a video I would look forward to your
walking iPad video next week I love
right and that's
what you have with your videos most
innovative channel / YouTube love this
yeah we're back to iPad day I usually
film these while I'm walking the whole
foods i'm super excited today's editing
day at my book they want editing day and
i walked the whole foods and I go on my
rant and then start filming and
answering your questions and sometimes
when I miss it I use Jason who's my my
videographer to help me film but I like
the iPad videos less polished as well to
something different next up ed hey
haven't been listening to podcast for
Eastleigh while commuting the work and
back I just finished season 2 of startup
it was amazing will we ever get a
believe podcast series and do you listen
to podcast if so could you recommend
some of them so it's a great question
and I think of all the things that I've
been asked to do the podcast has been
probably the most requested I've looked
into it looked into details of how to do
it I don't feel like it's coming anytime
soon the biggest reason is I just don't
want to have an extra platform to have
to worry about and I know it can be
hands-off and I know you know once you
set it up it can just automatically
upload YouTube videos that I have and it
doesn't take a lot of time each time but
i don't know i don't like doing things
half-assed and I feel like if I'm going
to get into the podcasting world then I
want to be able to do it right you know
put my stamp on it and so it's on my
maybe list of all the things people are
telling me to get into periscope and
meerkat and snapchat and blab and in
podcasting all these different things
podcast would probably the top of the
list but for now at least I'm a YouTube
mainly person and who knows that might
change I might wake up one day and feel
inspired and go after it but those are
my thoughts for now and terms of
listening to podcasts the only one that
I sometimes listen to is Tim Faris's in
general I'm a big Tim Ferriss fan I love
his books for work especially and the
other two were okay I was a huge reader
of his blog when he was active on it and
so I followed him to his TV show and his
podcast I find the podcast just kind of
boring sometimes I don't know to
scientific too long there are some
nuggets but it takes too long to get to
them so I listened to them sporadically
but that's the only 1i think podcasts
work well when you have a commute
we're me I don't really have a commute
and so I don't have to worry about how
am I gonna entertain myself during that
commute so some people suggest you could
download these turn them into an mp3 and
listen to them I realize it's an extra
step for you guys and really appreciate
the guys who are doing that but again on
my radar but not a high priority at the
moment next up Z know everyone I feel
like you're an open person willing to
listen to or in this case read what
viewers have to say so I feel
comfortable enough to say you seem kind
of agitated in this video maybe it's
because of the first part of the video
but it shows throughout the entire video
you didn't seem like usual jolly Evan
which to me made it slightly just
slightly less enjoyable to watch just
wanted to let you know Xena really
appreciate that I do listen I do read
all the comments uh uh you know I love
seeing to come in neenah highlights a
bunch of them for me to that she wants
me to directly answer I love I love your
feedback again you guys what drive my
channel it's interesting that the
there's a message there I feel in what
you wrote and one yes I was agitated I
came off from going to the CN Tower
which was a terrible day of the day
before we're referencing my video from
last week Christina we can maybe link
that up on the side and it was honestly
one of the most stressful days in the
past five years of my life I hate being
late for things I hate bad service I
hate being shuffled around I hate not
being prepared and be able to get my
stuff done on time and just it was super
stressful and the scene tower could have
made it so easy and that carried through
to to my next day and recording the
videos and so yes I was agitated and you
know I try to give you guys an honest
view of what I'm thinking when I'm
thinking why I'm thinking and so most
days I'm pretty jolly I'm one of the
most optimistic happy people that I know
but everybody has days when they get
frustrated and agitated and so I share
that with you guys too so you know you
guys get a sense of hey I'm not perfect
I'm not always happy and I think that
deeper lesson the deeper meaning in that
comment was I had a bad experience and
that tainted not only that day for me
but the next day because I recorded that
video a day later and
it goes to show you about your
surroundings and your environment how
important it is to you being creative
being happy and getting the stuff done
in your life that you want to accomplish
so if you are in that scenario on a
daily basis if you're surrounded by
people who make you unhappy who make you
stressed out who who don't believe in
you then you're going to be like that
too right you're going to be like I was
every single day and so it's important
to create an environment that builds you
up that supports you that makes you want
to go and crush your dreams last
question profit profit can you do a draw
my life would be awesome I really
appreciate your work I know John my life
was a huge trend maybe a couple years
ago I haven't seen much of it happening
which which is okay don't really care so
much about trends I'm not a great drawer
I'm a really poor artist I might be fun
to see if Hayden could draw some things
I tell him what to draw and he puts it
together I'll think about that it's an
interesting idea I'll think about that
and put it on my radar thank you for the
suggestion so the theme of today's video
is about being different and I would
love to know what you've done
specifically about malin success how
you've made how you've modeled different
people to then make you different what
you pull from different successful
entrepreneurs are people in your life to
make you the best version of yourself I
love you can leave them in the comments
below I'm going to join in the
discussion really appreciate all your
support and love I'm really excited to
be heading to whole foods now to finally
get to editing the book and I released
not letting you guys know about it leave
a comment below I'll join the discussion
continued to believe and I'll see you
soon